welcome to the vile villager the show
where we play as the meanest biggest POS
possible in Animal Crossing New Horizons
Jake you've played a lie this game and
we're trying to do just that right
I have played 80 hours of this game
actually I think I've played 90 by now
I've played a lot but as most people do
I've been taking it very seriously for
the most part I want my Island to be
perfect I don't write offend any of my
villagers mm-hmm I want everything to go
as smooth as possible right but that's
where this comes in because we are just
going to ruin this this village or this
island are you sir yeah the ice let's
start with the eyes is pretty important
the eyes are very prominent with Animal
Crossing characters let's go they're all
kind of terrifying in a way yeah they
all are oh I don't like those oh is it
Battle Royale
yeah where we drop them this reminds me
of like penny wise this is kind of a
little creepy but we're good yeah I know
we're normal this is kind of creepy
right yeah that is a bit strange these
are just watching you and then just
right as close as possible all right
back to back cuz yeah cuz we're gonna
get more villagers later and we're gonna
need to fit as many as we can in this
section okay there it is for here comes
scene I'm ready
Antonio ranae welcome to The Meat House
[Music]
if only they could Wow likely no water
perfect they love it oh look they love
it mm-hmm I'll find you a spot we can
set up some watchtowers around it yep
watchtower oh I mean you know keep an
eye on them they're wild animals after
all it's a form of quarantine
nope never bottles never use the
smartphone a gun worse what yeah keep
walking stop clapping that's not gonna
that's not gonna not make me laugh dude
I love this that charged up you peach
there okay good
all right meat house miles gotta claim
them it's got a nice little ring to it
huh
[Laughter]
I forget who we even have in this town
it's Renee Antonio Oh Renee there we go
perfect Oh Renee Antonio is our new
friend
Oh what vilas is crazy
that were almost oh my god when they do
that especially in the ponds I feel like
they just viciously oh come on
carp gotcha
Wow Jake Wow
I've played a lot of this game in this
exact time of this exact month so I know
everything you can get so you can't like
push them in the water yeah I want to
wrestle oh look who it is
Antonio and that's gonna be it for the
meet house Island we'll see you guys
next time take care bye ye